[Music]
then it burns new oh if burning and
burning is burn submitted by Daniela
loves JK crew Thank You Daniela a high
school is under fire for pepper spraying
students as a class Wow that [ __ ]
Thai dude the teacher just goes like
that and the guys hi huh did you see it
no that should help every spray works I
saw it I thought as a meme pepper spray
is one of those things to you actually
do have to aim it like you can't what
was the difference between service brand
me makes is a chemical spray they just
will Christian rapper yeah Ali and all
about me not about that was cloud formed
and then pepper spray is actually a
stream like that so it's not as you know
it works I mean if it even gets like
here it'll like go into your eyes but
you do have to aim it you can't like get
them in the belly button and then you
expect it to go up here you mean like
mace teeth that means is that everything
you get suck - right well you'd have to
be away yes yeah you're not doing it
from here there's this Ohio high school
that had their students so by the way
this was volunteered like the students
volunteers for this activity okay I want
to do that yeah and the parents also had
to give permission and there were
parents that were there witnessing this
entire thing so it is all legal
yeah everyone is in the know it's not
some change to it that happen like there
was just a lot of backlash from people
on the internet because this video went
viral a a parent was filming that video
but they didn't know that like these
people that was commenting meeting other
parents were there for some reason I
don't know commenters ever known TV they
don't know farmers make up their own
[ __ ] story and start bitching that's
just the Internet so then yeah there was
just people like a hashtag fire this
teacher this is unacceptable like you
know that this isn't funny like how can
they even be doing this to the students
the parents have to say that are
standing right next to them
exactly sit there Janna base you know
all the parents were there I'm not sure
if they're all there but this was part
of a class in law and public safety and
the instructor himself he was actually
uh he was previously a police officer
himself Otto but he's done this multiple
times
he knows what he's doing yeah you're the
former police chief oh yeah Oh keep
Wiggum oh he was doing and it was also a
school resource officer present as well
just in case they got backups a backup
sub backup and a school mascot was off
of it I don't like your school though
I'm pretty sure they'd do it right so I
don't for my head the way the story goes
is like okay all these like kids are
getting pepper sprayed I don't think
what did they do wrong I just go oh must
be some kind of school event [ __ ] where
I'm like duh they're probably signing
[ __ ] and doing stuff yeah and everything
they're going to be doing it without
permission depending on the area to know
sometimes because I'm not teachers be
getting jumped and they're probably set
up puppies kids and the kids didn't look
like they're being abused yeah I'll show
you guys ready to receive it like that
which Allah no yeah just watch just
watch the videos it look like they're
being abused yeah and just so you guys
know a lot of these students they
decided to participate in this activity
because blood them want to pursue like
law enforcement or be in the military I
work at Tapatio or that so that's the
reason why they want to work at the red
rooster sauce factory it's either work
at the basco or be a cop although you
just do it here we go whoo these high
school kids are being hit with pepper
spray by their teacher look if he goes
down the line screens are up Tom the
teenagers scream in agony as the effects
of again some riding pain the screen
just before another that just was like a
death metal
the shocking video shot by a parent is
causing a firestorm on social media
drive rate was a top and you know stupid
[Applause]
high school outside Akron Ohio the
teacher of the town's former police
chief Jeremy Milford the parents of all
the student remind waivers which war
dear parent or guardian each student
will receive a quick burst with since
chemical agent it will cause irritation
and a burning sensation to the eyes in
navel area for approximately an hour I
worked with mom Melanie nine hours about
yeah that's her son Zack got you're gone
I honestly had no idea it would be that
painful but I was proud I was proud of
all the kids that did it hurt for a
couple day it does what you out though I
got sprayed well you got friends yeah
yeah I got sprayed oh because some
[ __ ] bashed my car when I was inside
the car and then they sprayed me down
there like road rage things well they
turned Jackie [ __ ] no they weren't it
was a fight huh no it was they thought
that I was trying to steal one of their
friends girlfriends or something yet and
then they signed on to her account and
then said hey I'm stranded I don't want
to be at the stupid party anymore come
pick me up and I'm like okay so I go to
this house and then they [ __ ] come
out with Matt I don't know why Denis
masks because I know who the [ __ ] they
are
and then they bash my car and start
pepper spraying me Wow yeah that is so
[ __ ] I should they could have just
pulled me out and beat my ass but none
of them wanted to touch me what the [ __ ]
yeah I think radio instead so I'm in the
car and then Mike they just started
smashing my windows up night I I think
like the adrenaline hit me and I
couldn't turn on the car like it just
kept trying and [ __ ] and then um when
they got my windows open they just
started pepper spraying the car and then
I was like [ __ ] that so then while
pepper-sprayed I drove out trying to
chase them down and then I was just like
like this driving like this yeah and in
the more the wind blew in my eyes the
more felt like those burning yeah it was
burning but then once the adrenaline hit
I feel like pepper spray doesn't work
that well because um yeah once you have
it just feels like freshness in your
eyes I'm a lucky yeah it's like so a
super strong Japanese eye drops but feel
like I got a lot of menthol my eyes cuz
I also feel good is like what you're
saying like it would be a better
situation if there was like adrenaline
you know because adrenaline kind of
helps a lot of things you know I mean
like people who get their arm broken in
car accidents you have a [ __ ] boat
popping on their farm and the adrenaline
just keeps McGill what happened what
happened accepting you know so that's
been over that hour away to like you
know so it's just pretty intense I mean
I you know from the most I've had it is
you know like when you talk like a
jalapeno and you know you get your IV
[ __ ] you know what I've been happening I
bet you the parents were like because
you know how like I can't beat my kids
but I can watch they do this and they're
like laughing like I'm gonna save and
record this [ __ ] because you follow
girls oh they look like their whole body
caught on fire yo man at the top of your
life yeah a couple of them Joe did you
see that one do next - what's his name
he was I did so cool I've been part of a
pepper-sprayed course right now put it
on for the military and what they had to
do they were they were certified like a
bunch of I think like military police
people and have to spray them and have
to do this corner so they first they
come and then after use this baton and
then fight someone for like how long
they got to come up to me and also on
hold on the pad enough to throw like 50
knees at me while I'm still trying to
take them down and then they go
somewhere else and you disarm someone
and come and have to arrest someone at
the end while I'll pepper spray that
sounds like a fun obstacle or entire
course and they go up to them and do
like like literally for like like
last part of the course right in the
beginning all in the beginning yet to do
it all with pepper spray already pepper
spray so under like confusion and
discombobulation you have to complete
the whole thing and they spray it on
like for five to ten seconds on the
forehead like this and then you could
just see it like dripping down and I
wasn't even part of being sprayed but
just me interacting with each person
that was coming to my station my eyes
were burning like a [ __ ] like
crazy and I was burning from just
contact for like the next eight hours
like they're pepper spray sweat is
coming to you yeah it was it was bad job
like some JK party [ __ ] right now and
all those guys the rest of the day they
were like they just had buckets and
buckets of milk and everyone was just
like all over the head and there for
like 30 seconds to a minute at a time it
was great it could be maybe like there's
police or military great pepper spraying
is way stronger than what a civilian can
get but I was like [ __ ] messages ah I
wonder what's inside pepper spray like
on this temple but there's other [ __ ]
too though right I did actually I know
there's like pepper oil right or some
[ __ ] I feel like there is I want to know
the guy who invented that military
training course like he was creative
like he should write games for us on JK
party that's why I would never be on
this show morning it's kind of like get
a bat [ __ ] spindly times and then get
a go over there I don't get a [ __ ]
uppercut in the stomach and then that's
not JK party anymore that's Joe moly in
training I wanted to do it but at the
end they found out that I want to
contact oh so you can't because the
chemical agent it binds to your contact
and if you're contacted on your I'll
find to it and if I took my contacts out
I'm completely blind so I'm going to
write one to the right station so
there's criteria like you have to be
like 2020 that or you can't wear glasses
or contacts you guys do all this stuff
yeah like if my eyes weren't Stevie
Wonder I would have been able to do it
oh not anymore I could do it I would
have been certified of being a military
police for the pepper spray course
oh so that's a course you need to do
before you become a military police or
whatever so you have to hold like like a
bunch of certifications and then you
qualify to be this so there are people
that don't pass that fort yeah there's
people think you may get sprayed there
just
and they can't do it and they can't
disarm people and maybe they can't pass
so the active ingredient in pepper spray
is those peppers
capsaicin our caps it was the position
yeah yeah it's that one I know like may
suppose to also suffocate you I'll
ferrell yeah it's supposed to suffocate
you from what i remember cuz my friend
tannic smell when he was doing so if
you're on campus security at Riverside
they also give you like mace or it's
called OC spray or some [ __ ] like that
and it's supposed to suffocate you too
so Bob and restrict your breathing too
as well yeah and there's a pepper spray
video they were telling all the students
don't open your mouth I'll be around
yeah immediately the [ __ ] you up all
over the place so that's how I feel
those videos of those guys who like it
when they're still like what's true you
know I'm like you guys or maybe they
have an inspired expired can they just
take water or they're on PCP there are
some guys on a hell of [ __ ] gangster
though so one thing that all Marines
have to do is the gas chamber and it's
kind of like it's kind of like pepper
spray it kept you go in and then they
like this being and it feels like when
you take your mask off it feels like a
thousand needles hitting your lungs so
when you go in there you just see people
like we're all surrounded we already
have a gas mask on and everyone's
surrounded in the room and immediately
one of the first things you have to do
is take it on I mean put on your
forehead and then just hold your breath
or you can breathe it for your gangster
and you put it back on and some people
at that point you just drop and ready so
[ __ ] crazy because it burns like a
month imagine like the ghost pepper that
we have but inside your lungs and then
the next thing that you have to do have
to take it off completely then put it
back on because they want you to teach
you to be able to do that under chemical
warfare but there's some gangster as
most husband I don't know if they're
like 40 years smoke or some [ __ ] that
that course is so easy because I've to
get certified every year they just go on
without the mask they don't even do the
whole thing so just there
you just breathe the chemicals and they
come out and they're still throwing up
afterwards because the chemical
reactions are so crazy but the fact that
it can even withstand it without the
mask is your what they should do ana
dope military test I just gone to this
right now they should have every [ __ ]
guy just walk blindfold at least done
just oh I see how you react
here at a big one the pinky because
that's convincing I've never seen
anybody stuff that told me life yo
everybody hidden couch test yeah you
have to walk to a living room and
everyday they move the customer yeah but
if they don't react gangster [ __ ] that
pepper spray [ __ ] that's [ __ ] funny
stub your toe test whoa Jay can use fans
I hope you guys liked that video once
again remember if you want to be
involved just submit some article them
I'll suck your dick now but seriously
though there's more videos up there
[Music]